bonsoir édition spéciale du 7-8
politique en ce lundi 7 décembre nous
allons revenir sur les résultats de ces
élections régionales sur ce premier tour
alors que vous voyez apparaître les
visages des trois candidats qualifiés en
ile-de-france pour le second tour
valérie pécresse claude bartolone et
vallerand de saint-just leurs trois
listes peuvent se maintenir pour débuter
les chiffres de l'abstention elle reste
forte en france même si elle est moins
élevée qu'aux dernières régionales de
2010 et un électeur sur deux ne s'est
toujours pas déplacés aux urnes on
notera qu'en ile de france et encore
moins bien 54 % d'abstention dans les
yvelines
on approche les 50 2% stéphane minson
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes professeur de
droit public à l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines à
l'institut d'études politiques aussi à
saint germain en laye vous allez nous
accompagner au cours de cette émission
avant de voir le détail des résultats
pour la région et pour le département
des yvelines mais aussi pour vos
différentes communes que peut-on dire
concernant l'abstention
une fois de plus les électeurs ne se
sont pas rendus aux urnes et mention
très passable aussi pour la région
ile-de-france en 54 % d'abstention une
fois de plus vous l'avez dit alors on
s'attendait on s'attendait presque à
pire donc je pense pas qu'il y ait
matière néanmoins se réjouir mais cela
dit oui mention mention passable voir
enfin un armés d'y entrer pour pour
l'île de france sas et peut enfin c'est
quand même moins fréquents j'avoue qu'on
pouvait s'attendre sans doute à un taux
de participation plus élevée et
notamment peut-être dans les yvelines
qui généralement sont un département
assez
assez civique de ce point de vue là
après les attentats les événements qui
se sont déroulés mi novembre on avait
parlé d'unité nationale les politiques
avaient espéré une mobilisation aux
urnes en tout cas il l'avait appelé n'a
pas eu vraiment lieu cette organisation
les sondages le laisser laissé assez
clairement apparaître si l'effet
attentats évidemment bénéficié au
président de la république
il a peut-être aussi on en parlera tout
à l'heure bénéficier au front national
sur la participation en effet n'y a pas
une mobilisation sur les fréquences qui
est pourtant la première région qui a
été qu'ils étaient concernés par ces
nids sur l'île de france on va découvrir
les différents résultats en détail à
commencer par ceux de l'île de france
valérie pécresse est donc en tête avec
plus de 30% des suffrages elle fait elle
cinq points de mieux que claude
bartolone seulement les républicains ont
fait le choix de partir groupé avec le
modem lui dei notamment l les réserves
de voix qui sont minces les socialistes
mist en revanche sur un report des voix
du front de gauche et les verts
et si cela fonctionne il pourrait
l'emporter en tout cas mathématiquement
c'était fanm ans on est à peu près dans
le même schéma qu'en 2010 en tout cas du
côté de la gauche il n'avait pas fait
l'union au premier tour et jean paul
huchon avait été devancé en revanche il
l'avait emporté au second tour avec un
rassemblement
certes mais sauf que en 2010 les
écologistes avec cécile duflot avait
fait 16 % là les écologistes font deux
fois - et non en tout état de cause ne
pouvait pas être qualifiée pour le
second tour de surcroît le front
national avait fait quant à lui deux
fois moins en 2010 9 et le voilà avec 18
ce qui le qualifie pour le second tour
donc second tour donnera lieu à une
triangulaire
ce qui change vraiment la donne par
rapport à 2010 effectivement puisque le
front national n'avait pas été qualifié
pour le second tour est d'ailleurs le
front national n'a aucun élu dans
l'assemblée sortante au conseil et au
conseil régional
du côté de la stratégie des républicains
d'avoir fait le choix de l'alliance dès
le début est de voir qu'aujourd'hui
finalement c'est assez peu en tout cas
en ile de france
enfin le mot niveau national mais
concernant l'île de france 30% pour le
score de valérie pécresse additionnées
avec lui dit le modem s'est pas vraiment
bon score c'est pas un bon score non
peut-être même fin lorsque le score
national en tout cas de cette de cette
union des droite parlementaire
du centre est plutôt globalement mauvais
on aurait sans doute pu s'attendre un
meilleur score au regard de rands en
tout cas de ce que laissait entendre les
sondages la droite parlementaire
c'est même si ça coûte c'est plutôt se
regrouper quand il le faut la gauche cet
autre chose ça veut dire que sur les
différents stands ans de droite
aujourd'hui elles sont un peu balayé on
ne fait plus la différence droite centre
tendance politique la droite enfin on a
vraiment aujourd'hui un paysage
politique français
tendance de gauche tendance de droite et
puis l'extrême droite je ne crois pas je
pense qu'il ya quand même quelques voix
dissonantes alors assez faible
faiblement audible qui sont faites
entendre notamment aujourd'hui à propos
de du fait de savoir s'il faut fusionner
s'il faut se retirer et cetera on
entendu nathalie kosciusko morizet jean
pierre raffarin a porté des voies très
différentes
alain juppé n'en pensait pas moins mais
semble-t-il a préféré priscilla ont
décidé de ne pas se désister
lorsque les listes à rétro absolument
donc je pense pas il n'y a pas de pour
l'instant en tout cas ça ne se dessine
pas de cette manière là un bloc très
monolithique de la droite parlementaire
les choses sont beaucoup plus subtil que
c'est en 2010 le modem n'était pas parti
avec l'ump ce n'est pas le cas cette
année est ce une bonne idée nous sommes
allés poser la question à bruno myle
yens celle responsable départemental du
modem les propos ont été recueillis par
fanny bourdilhan par téléphone
franchement autour de ce projet là moi
je pense que c'est la meilleure idée
qu'on ait eu mal est fait par heymans
était juste sucre un suicidaire de yali
séparément pour finalement porter chacun
de notre côté à peu près le même projet
je vois pas vraiment l'intérêt quand les
projets sont diamétralement opposés
c'est normal d'y aller tout seul
d'après ya pas de fusion possible au
deuxième tour c'est si simple qu'elle
reproche aux écologie au front de gauche
et au parti socialiste je suis désolé
leurs projets ne sont pas les mêmes
au deuxième tout d'un coup ils vont
s'entendre mais mes fesses et c'est de
la magie fin c'est lui la poudre aux
yeux on se fout de la gueule du monde
et c'est justement selon le français
veulent plus pour réagir à ce qui vient
d'être dit para one au millième pour le
pour le modem aujourd'hui rassembler ces
différentes formations de gauche qui se
sont déchirés en tous cas presque
pendant la campagne autour d'un seul et
même projet du côté de l'opinion
publique ça va ça va prendre
je mange pas sur le fond c'est très
compliqué parce qu'on a vu à quel point
depuis
depuis 2012 et spécifiquement depuis un
an et demi à peu près une très très
forte division entre les différents
partis à gauche les frondeurs et serrait
pas seulement il reste que politiquement
parfois nécessité fait loi et que
lorsque c'est la seule solution qui vous
reste eh bien voilà il ya plus le choix
pour faire un petit focus sur europe
écologie les verts vous l'avez dit tout
à l'heure
premier tour des régionales en île de
france étaient 16% en 2010 diviser par
deux le score pour pour cette année ça
veut dire que pour europe ecologie les
verts les choses sont graves
historiquement cette formation politique
à vis des hauts et des bas là on est
encore une fois dans un creux mais elle
a su se reprendre
ça peut encore arriver ça y est les
cadres qui sont partis entre toi y ait
beaucoup de remous ces dames charmant
mais mais du côté du côté des
écologistes du moins en france et c'est
pas d'ailleurs spécifique à la france on
remarque ça un peu dans d'autres partis
écologistes en europe il ya toujours eu
beaucoup de beaucoup de mouvement c'est
une espèce de volcan en fusion
permanente pour essayer de faire en
sorte d'avoir un parti monolithique qui
ne parle que d'une seule voix ça c'est
vrai que c'est pas la peine même pas la
peine d'y penser
donc là en effet je pense que les très
fortes divisions qui ont traversé les
verts au cours de la dernière année
de toute évidence ont desservi cette
formation politique qui divise par deux
son score il faut dire quand même qu'en
2010 le score avait été
exceptionnellement 16% c'était énorme
sur une dynamique qui avait suivi les
élections européennes à l'époque
là on est peut-être un étiage un peu
plus entre guillemets un peu plus
traditionnel mais divisé son score par
deux pour europe ecologie les verts en
pleine négociation autour de la coop 21
on n'a jamais parlé autant
d'environnements ça peut paraître
surprenant c'est pas forcément
surprenant parce que vous aurez remarqué
que depuis maintenant assez longtemps
la thématique de l'écologie alors tout
dépend de ce que l'on entend par là mais
la thématique de l'écologie infuse
la quasi totalité des partis chaque
partie maintenant défend un programme
alors c'est peut-être c'était d'ailleurs
le succès au moins partielle de deux
lits des écologistes qui me confine à la
disparition du parti du même nom nous
allons regarder à présent les différents
chiffres dans les yvelines à l'issue de
ce premier tour vous les avez déjà
aperçu on constate que la liste de
valérie pécresse a beaucoup plus d'
avance dans le département qu'au niveau
régional sur celle de claude bartelone
le département est clairement ancré à
droite les socialistes ne sont que deux
points au dessus du front national 21%
contre 19% pour la formation de marine
le pen après les départementales les
municipales c'est un nouveau revers pour
les socialistes dans le département est
ce qu'on peut dire ça où est-ce qu'ils
s'en sortent plutôt bien
écoutez je trouve que les socialistes
alors dans le département comme sur le
plan national s'en sortent passe ne s'en
sortent pas si mal que cela
en tout cas c'est moins pire que ce qui
était attendu au regard des sondages
alors dans les yvelines est évidemment
valérie pécresse est entre guillemets
chez elle on sait que c'est son fief à
l'instar d'ailleurs de claude bartolone
dans en seine saint denis qui lui aussi
a pris la tête des des résultats mais
c'est plus si vous voulez un
effondrement des écologistes avec un
parfois aussi un faible score du front
de gauche qui aboutit à tirer les
formations de gauche vers le bas mais le
parti socialiste au fond ne s'en sort
pas si mal que cela le front de gauche
dans le département des yvelines qui
totalise 3,8 pour cent qui n'arrive même
pas à la barre des 4% et une formation
dont on a finalement encore assez peu
parlé c'est le front national le front
national en ile de france c'est 18% 19%
dans les yvelines c'est beaucoup plus
qu'en 2010 on rappelle donc une nouvelle
fois que dans la mandature qui s'achève
il n'y avait pas d'élu front national en
ile de france
malgré tout c'est quand même une
progression nette est aussi dans
l'ensemble des autres régions comme
comment vous expliquer comment on peut
expliquer le score de vallerand de
saint-just 18% c'est finalement le
quasiment le plus mauvais score du front
national en france
oui mais vous rendez compte que 18 % et
par de mauvais score alors il est
affilié
alors qu'il a il à 100% pour la
sensation de plus
par rapport à 2010 donc c'est déjà c'est
déjà un score énorme pour l'île de
france l'est avec une autre tête
d'affiché on va dire parce que verlan de
saint-just et trésorier et avocat de
cette formation politique il était un
petit peu inconnu c'est un peu avant
avant ce scrutin avec une autre tête
d'affiché comme marine le pen par
exemple on aurait pu atteindre 40 % pour
le front national en ile de france
ça ça m'étonnerait je pense pas qu on
ait pu parvenir on puisse parvenir
jusqu'à un tel score le fait est que
valeur de saint-just a bénéficié de
cette dynamique à l'oeuvre
certains disent depuis 1984 et
spécifiquement depuis 2011 depuis que
marine le pen a pris les rênes de ce
parti familial ça il ya eu un effet
d'entraînement qui est incontestable de
là à dire qu'avec marine le pen en
ile-de-france le fn ne serait parvenu à
40% je ne pense pas qu'on puisse
s'aventurer jusqu'à quelques
infographies qui concerne le front
national dans les yvelines mantes la
ville tout d'abord la liste de 20 land
saint-just est première avec un peu plus
de 34% vous allez le voir c'est le
meilleur score dans le département des
yvelines va le rendre saint-just 34%
c'est une ville qui est détenu un set
cette commune est détenue par le front
national déjà et il ya une forte
abstention attrape la liste front
national et 2e 18,80 % est là aussi
point commun avec les montres la ville
c'est l'abstention qui est forte c'est
60% d'abstention amante 69% à trappes
l'abstention profite au parti d'extrême
droite c'est ça la conclusion complet
c'est plus compliqué là c'était
compliqué
l'abstention et l'absention n'est pas un
parti dans sa composition la composition
des abstentionnistes est hétérogène ce
qu'on peut dire en tout cas à l'opposé
c'est que le corps électoral du front
national lui et le corps électoral la
partie du corps électoral toujours qui
est la plus mobilisée à chaque scrutin
on le voit donc ce sont des gens qui de
toute façon vont jeter quoi qu'il arrive
et on sait qu on estime à à peu près 50%
la part des abstentionnistes qui s'ils
s'étaient déplacés auraient plutôt voté
à gauche ça aussi c'est un schéma qui
est plutôt classique
ses fans dans son confesseur de droit
public vous restez avec nous pour la
suite de cette édition spéciale du 7-8
politique en ce lundi 7 décembre nous
dressons les résultats en ile de france
dans les yvelines et dans vos
différentes communes
de ces régionales pour l'instant un
micro trottoir c'est vous qui réagissent
et micro trottoir signé jeremy quesada
que pensez vous de ces résultats dans
votre région je trouve que l'élection
d'ile-de-france et le reflète assez bien
le comment dirais-je panel politique
ça fait quand même trois mandatures pour
le parti socialiste et la gauche c'est
logique que les électeurs aient envie
d'avoir du changement dans l'île de
france je me l'expliquent pas avec le
chômage avec eux comment dirais-je les
déprime qui était octroyé qui sont ou
ont été supprimés tout un tas plus quoi
je pense que les gens quand même aussi
son veulent pas tomber dans l'extrême
quoi je trouve que c'est tous des
charlots voilà c'est tout j'aimerais que
tous ces messieurs qui sont gouvernement
réfléchissent pendant la semaine à venir
bien que ce soit un peu court
j'aimerais vous faire réagir parce que
par rapport à ce qu'on vient d'entendre
là on entend souvent les politiques dire
je vous ai entendu je vous ai compris
pour nous dans une formule déjà bien
utilisé et qui date quand même un petit
peu
est ce qu'ils ont vraiment compris le
message les politiques écoutent et ils
peuvent pas tenir un autre discours en
tout cas l'un vers ce serait malvenu je
ne vous écoute pas je ne vous entends
pas et je ne vous ai pas compris ça se
traduise dans les faits sauf que sauf
que ça fait 30 ans que le front national
est dans une pente ascendante alors avec
quelques petites pauses notamment avec
la scission mégret en 97 18 mai ça fait
30 ans que le front national est à
l'oeuvre les fruits commencent
maintenant être récoltés la moisson
commence à être effectuée le fait est
que les solutions si solution il y a
ne sont pas immédiates ne sont pas ne
peuvent pas être défait immédiat on
s'embarque dans on s'engage dans une
dans une espèce de marathon de très
longue haleine
ce conte reprécise que c'était le
dernier scrutin avant la présidentielle
de 2017 d'où l'importance de ce scrutin
des régionales ne serait-ce que de
valeur test un petit peu pour tester les
différentes personnalités politiques qui
pourraient se présenter en 2017 pour la
présidentielle avant de revenir sur les
différents résultats sachez que demain à
18 heures en direct sur tv films nous
vous proposerons un débat entre les
différents candidats en ile de france
david douillet député des républicains
benoît hamon député ps et philippe
chevrier responsable départemental du
front national seront sûrs
ce plateau ils sont tous les trois
candidats en attendant je vous propose à
présent de partir pour le quartier
général de valérie pécresse à paris nous
y avons suivi sa campagne hier soir sur
place floren parfait près de 22 heures
au quartier général des républicains
rues de turin à paris valérie pécresse
va prononcer son discours
la candidate les républicains arrive
première en remportant 36 51 % des
suffrages en ile de france devant le
socialiste claude bartolone crédité lui
de 25,19 % des voix et va les rangs de
saint-just candidat front national avec
18 41% des suffrages un résultat en demi
teinte pour celle qui était crédité à
33% des voix dans les derniers sondages
de ces élections régionales et à ceux
qui n'ont pas voté pour la liste que je
conduis je veux dire que j'ai entendu
votre colère je sais que vous avez perdu
confiance dans la politique vous
attendez beaucoup plus de vos élus plus
de sécurité mais aussi plus d'espoir
plus d'engagement plus de conviction
plus d'honnêteté
ce que je vous propose ce sont des
solutions concrètes pour obtenir enfin
des résultats
depuis cinq ans la députée yvelinoise
s'est engagé pour ces élections
en 2010 elle avait perdu face à jean
paul huchon avec un écart de plus de 10
points
imaginez que cette région était tenue
par la gauche qu'elle était tenue par la
gauche depuis 17 ans et valérie pécresse
arrive largement en tête c'est quand
même une très très belle victoire mais
je crois que
c'est d'abord la victoire de sa campagne
l'ancien ministre de l'enseignement a
conclu une alliance entre lui diy le
modem afin de fédérer un grand nombre
d'électeurs
les réserves de voix pour les
républicains sont donc faibles pour le
second tour
ils l'assurent la campagne ne va pas
altérer sa travail de fourmi c'est c'est
allé frapper à chaque porte c'est allez
expliquer à chaque personne c'est être
encore et encore plus à la rencontre des
franciliens pour leur expliquer les
compétences de la région que cela est
extrêmement important et leur les
convaincre que notre projet est un
projet réaliste c'est dans son
département d'origine que la candidate
obtient le deuxième meilleur score avec
37,23 % des voix juste derrière les
hauts de seine où elle s'est placée en
tête avec 39 64 % des suffrages exprimés
mais à une semaine du deuxième tour la
chasse au vote est relancé
première cible les abstentionnistes en
ile-de-france le taux d'abstention
s'élève à 54,11 pour 151 points 82 pour
les yvelines un phénomène à prendre en
compte pour l'emporter face au ps comme
à trappes où il s'élève à près de 70%
on regrette bien sûr mais ça changera
pas l'issue du scrutin est vraiment les
électeurs qui sont insatisfaits devrait
plutôt venir sanctionner ceux qui sont
au pouvoir
en ile de france donc c'est voter pour
valérie pécresse parce que c'est la
seule qui peut l'emporter plutôt que de
rester chez eux
même si je peux comprendre que la
politique ne fait pas toujours rêvé pour
le second tour l'ex de campagne reste le
même
transport chômage mais surtout sécurité
alors chers francilienne cher
franciliens vous pouvez compter sur moi
pour rétablir l'autorité les valeurs
républicaines pour lutter contre le
communautarisme les trafics et la
radicalisation l'adversaire principal de
ce deuxième tour est le parti socialiste
et si en ile de france le front national
réalise son deuxième plus mauvais score
derrière la bretagne avec 18 41 % des
voix ce score est comme partout en
france en très nette hausse est deux
fois plus important qu'il ya cinq ans et
sur la liste de valérie pécresse figure
dans les yvelines véronique côté millard
c'est à la mairie des idées
clayes-sous-bois voici les chiffres dans
sa commune ils sont très serrés 29 99
contre 27 56 pour claude bartolone et le
front national qui frôle
les 20% nous sommes allés recueillir sa
réaction camille lambert pour un général
a parlé d'élections municipales les
comment dire de la ville la gauche est
toujours en tête dans la commune des
clayes sous bois
c'est une victoire c'est d'autant plus
une victoire en 2010 valérie pécresse
avait fait 25 janvier vivent à la nasa
presque 30
autant je peux comprendre même si je
veux trop pressés ou que c'est
malheureusement ce cri de colère et les
personnes qui ont voté front national et
ce cri de colère et d'espoir pas autant
je peux le comprendre le même si je
fasse je souhaitais pas d'une solution
parce que des faits n'apportera pas de
solution confrères ne peut apporter que
des divisions et nous aider nous
enfoncer davantage
autant je suis surprise par parle par le
score du parti clanique obus deux obus
de voilà au vu de l'actualité au vu de
ce qui s'est passé à la région au vu de
ce qu'elle dénonce et qui vrai qui est
une baignade jdd transformer une
catastrophe
l'emploi de capèle france le chômage
augmente la formation des profs
donc je suis surpris nous irons tout à
l'heure aux quartiers généraux de claude
bartolone et de vallerand de saint-just
nous y étions aussi reçoit on va encore
parler un petit peu des résultats pour
la droite dans les yvelines on le disait
tout à l'heure la liste des républicains
est en tête et beaucoup plus largement
dans certaines communes le score des
républicains et dépasse les 30% c'est le
cas à villepreux avec le 32,54 % c'est
le cas également à rambouillet la ville
du président du sénat républicain gérard
larcher valérie pécresse y totalise
presque 34 % et puis à versailles et ce
score très net 47,40 % et l'abstention a
été plus faible que dans le reste du
département avec 53 % de votants même
chose du côté de voisins-le-bretonneux
les républicains totalisent 40 4,51 pour
cent l'abstention est seulement de 45%
globalement sur l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines les résultats des
dernières municipales et départementales
sont confortés la gauche est plutôt à la
peine
valérie pécresse arrive en tête dans 4
des 7 communes de la communauté
d'agglomération à montigny-le-bretonneux
elancourt voisins le bretonneux vous
l'avez vu ou encore manille
moreau la candidate de l'union de la
droite a réalisé son meilleur score
vous l'avez vu à voisins le bretonneux
le président de la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines était au micro de michael et
demi d'euros et c'est à présent qu'on
m'écoute je ne suis pas surpris bien sûr
que valérie réalise son meilleur score à
vos seins de bretenoux c'est un
électorat qui lui est fidèle et donc
c'est très bien pour elle d'autant que
voisins le bretonneux fait aussi partie
de ça ces conceptions et on voit bien
que aussi le score excellent qu'elle
réalise sur magny les hameaux qui à la
base était de communes de qui n'est pas
géré par le même parti qu'elle donc
beaucoup de satisfaction dans les rangs
des résultats sur la totalité du
territoire saint quentinois
mais en tout cas on voit bien aussi que
sur même le le grand saint quentin le
futur territoire que nous aurons à
partir de 1er janvier est bien rodée à
peu près dans la même tendance c'est à
dire
valérie pécresse arrive qu'on tête dans
neuf des 12 communes ce qui est quand
même un résultat exceptionnel
et puisque nous sommes allés voir michel
logis pour parler de la communauté
d'agglomération nous sommes aussi allés
le voir pour qu'il nous parle de sa
commune de montigny le bretonneux à
montigny le bretonneux valérie pécresse
arrive donc en tête deuxième position la
liste socialiste avec un peu plus de 27%
des voix le fn est troisième avec 13% et
les verts aussi sont à la quatrième
place avec 9 hercules 51%
est ce qui est plutôt un score plus
élevé par rapport au reste est de l île
de france où on écoute à nouveau michel
laugier
je suis plutôt satisfait puisque valérie
arrive largement en tête sur montigny
donc déjà c'est une bonne satisfaction
deuxièmement j'ai regardé aussi le score
du front national c'était intéressant
par rapport au tout ce qui se passait en
france et chez nous aussi il est très
bien maîtrisé donc je ne peux qu'être
satisfait du résultat de ce premier
toute mécanique au premier tour il faut
continuer à travailler pour que le
deuxième tour soit transformé les
stéphanois sont pour le département pour
l'agglomération constate que le rapport
de force a été bien confirmer la droite
domine dans ce département des yvelines
et le fn est plutôt contenue finalement
rien de neuf là ça fait on est on est
dans une terre une terre de la droite
parlementaire
dynamiser les derniers scrutins il ya
bien conforter la droite il n'ya plus
d'élus par exemple socialiste ou d'une
autre c'est leur politique au sein du
conseil département sous le nom oui mais
cette tendance là elle elle est alors
elle s'amplifie pas un mais mais c'est
l'un des bastions de la droite
parlementaire en ile de france
voilà manière très classique ça va être
compliqué maintenant pour la gauche de
s'imposer d'inverser un petit peu la
tendance est ce que historiquement des
cas de figure comme ça sont déjà
présentés en plus je pense à saint
quentin en yvelines et on l'a entendu
michel laugier tout à l'heure avec le
futur 50 ans libre et le grand saint
quentin en yvelines qui va apporter
encore plus de poids à la droite c'est
des communes comme guyancourt qui sont à
gauche ou encore la verrière oumhani
même si on verra tout à l'heure que
c'est valérie pécresse qui l'emporté au
premier tour vont être un petit peu
esseulé oui oui ils vont évidemment être
un petit peu esseulé mais ce que vous
disiez en débutant votre propos à savoir
est-ce que ce que ça va durer et des
rares en politique faut jamais jamais
rien et à qui vous aviez aux alentours
autour de saint quentin en yvelines afin
qu'il n'existait pas à l'époque allant
77 des bastions communistes qui ont fini
par basculer du côté des socialistes ce
qui a entraîné des changements très très
importants
donc voilà avoir à voir mais en tout cas
ce scrutin n'illustre pas une évolution
notable de ce point de vue on va parler
d'elle en cours à présent sur cette
commune aussi la droite l'emportent 33
49% pour valérie pécresse six points de
mieux que claude bartolone le fn est à
16 % on écoute jean michel fourgous le
maire d'elancourt pour un coup d'essai
c'est quand même six points neuf ans je
crois par rapport à son par rapport à
donc bartelone côté je pense que les
devants m'ont quand même largement sais
pas c'est pas un demi point maintenant
il faut confirmer l'essai bien sûr au
deuxième tour mais je pense que c'est
une fille anne est une fille compétente
ou un ring ça épuise une fille tiennent
là leur travail tels que je laime tels
que moi je me retrouve bien ces valeurs
là 7,8 politique se poursuit nous allons
partir dans un instant au qg de claude
bartolone juste avant un détour par
magny les hameaux
c'est une commune détenue par la gauche
en plomb municipal commune emblématique
aussi de cette rivalité gauche droite
ces dernières années c'est valérie
pécresse qui arrive en tête 32 23% et à
26% pour le ps stéphane le manceau est
ce que c'est significatif ce score
est-ce qu'il faut se fier aux élections
régionales pour y voir là non non non
non en tout état de cause on sait que
les scores obtenus dans les communes au
scrutin au scrutin d'envergure nationale
et on peut dire que ce scrutin bien que
scrutin local était un scrutin
d'envergure nationale puisque les
questions régionales
du moins dans la seconde partie de la
campagne de la non campagne n'ont
absolument pas été abordé dans la
déclaration faite par les leaders
politiques donc le score obtenu à la
présidentielle aux régionales ou
départementales dans une commune ne
n'est pas nécessairement significatif du
score que le maire ou que l'équipe
municipale sera en mesure d'espérer aux
prochaines élections à montigny on sait
que assez souvent montini vote plutôt à
gauche aux présidentielles mais j'aurais
plutôt centre-droit aux municipales
alors il ya jamais toutefois une réserve
dans ce que je dis au regard des 11
communes c'est pas significatif parce
que onze communes sur 36 1700 sais rien
mais elle est conçue comme une tenue par
le front national
on a la faveur des élections régionales
rééditer une adhésion vous l'avait dit
pour moi que là vraiment que la mère
d'élise est donc très forte pour le
front national dans le département
jusqu'à une parenthèse pour rebondir ce
que sur ce que vous venez de dire est
par rapport aux différentes déclarations
on va le voir au cours de cette édition
du 7 8 politique aujourd'hui on ne parle
pas du tout des compétences du conseil
régional dans la campagne c'est encore
moi déjà pas hier mais encore moins
aujourd'hui c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire alors non seulement on parle pas
des compétences du conseil régional
mais mais surtout enfin il est bon il
n'y a pas eu de campagne ccc on parle
alors si ce n'est que effectivement on
parle de questions qui sont tous sur des
questions de compétence régionale
il est bien évident et ça a déjà été
suffisamment écrit et dit que la région
est une collectivité territoriale qui ne
dispose d' absolument aucune compétence
relative à l'ordre public à la sécurité
etc y compris la police ferroviaire vous
savez les agents qu'on trouve dans le
dans le rer etc relèvent de la
compétence du préfet de police de paris
donc et pas de la région pas du stif
donc voilà alors une fois que vous avez
dit que la région est compétente en
matière d'enseignement d'apprentissage
et de transport vous avez à peu près
fait le tour si ce n'est que la région
est aussi une collectivité territoriale
chef de file en matière de développement
économique donc certain que ça peut être
un levier économique assez assez
intéressant notamment la région gère les
fonds structurels européens ce qui n'est
pas rien mais cela dit c'est vrai qu'à
entendre les les différents chefs de
partis et et tête de liste qui se sont
exprimés quand on parle de sécurité en
matière d'élections régionales
on se trompe de scrutin nous écoutons à
présent puisque nous retournons pouvoir
manier les amours après cette parenthèse
on écoute bertrand oui on le maire de la
commune et roire berger la responsable
de l'opposition des républicains à
manille dont 32% comme quand on regarde
les résultats sur la commune les
résultats à l'échelle de la région en
fait c'est les même quasiment donc
aujourd'hui ce qui importe c'est le
rassemblement de toute la gauche puisque
toute la gauche rassemblée on a 40% ce
qui est inquiétant c'est la
participation qui reste faible et donc
le peu d'intérêt des habitants pour une
région qui a quand même des compétences
qui sont conséquentes dans le quotidien
des habitants
j'espérais que valérie pécresse puisse
terminer en tête de cette élection c'est
pas une surprise parce que valérie
quelqu'un qui est connu sur sur cette
ville c'est la députée de la
circonscription
elle est venue de très nombreuses fois
mais nullement où elle s'est battue sur
des sujets par exemple l'interdiction
des forages pétroliers dont calais elle
est connue et je pense que son travail
est reconnu
en tout cas c'est enlever la preuve
quand elle est placée nettement en tête
au premier tour
vous venez nous rejoindre nous faisons
le point sur ce premier tour des
régionales en ile-de-france valérie
pécresse est en tête néanmoins la gauche
espère l'emporter pour cela elle va
miser sur un report des voix europe
ecologie les verts et front de gauche la
soirée d'hier en tout cas été agitée au
siège de claude bartolone nous y étions
les images sont signés patrick jacques
de dixmude un des visages fermés des
premières tendances pessimiste et
l'éventualité de voir le parti
socialiste terminé à la troisième place
de ce premier tour des régionales
derrière le front national
au siège de campagne de claude bartolone
les élus se font rares l'ambiance est
pesante
le premier parti c'est l'abstention est
donc voilà après la gauche
est partie divisée au premier tour elle
ne sera pas au second
je pense qu'il y aura aussi à une prise
de conscience d'un certain nombre
d'électeurs abstentionnistes qui se
rendront montrent qu' il ya un sursaut
démocratique et républicain qui est
nécessaire à 20h annonce officielle des
premiers résultats la machine front
national est lancé l'inquiétude se
transforme en angoisse quand finalement
les chiffres en ile-de-france tombe le
premier message c'est que tous les
électeurs qui souhaitent que
l'ile-de-france reste toi les rentes ou
verts fraternels et envoie ce message au
reste de la france et au reste du monde
et qu'on se rassemble derrière claude
bartolone des écologistes le reste de la
gauche et tout ceux qui sont attachés à
cette image de de l'ile-de-france donc
j'espère que ce sera ça dimanche
prochain en ile-de-france le parti
socialiste et ses alliés dont le parti
radical gauche arrive deuxième avec
25,19 % des suffrages exprimés
si les voix des électeurs europe
ecologie les verts et front de gauche se
reportent sur la candidature de claude
bartolone la gauche pourrait conserver
la région
ce soir la gauche est en tête en ile de
france j'en appelle au peuple de gauche
et à tous les écologistes en ile de
france
j'appelle au plus large rassemblement
un rassemblement total pas une boîte de
gauche et des écologistes ne doit
manquer dimanche prochain dans les
yvelines le parti socialiste ne totalise
en revanche qu'un peu plus de 21% ses 16
points de moins que la liste d'union de
la droite et seulement deux points de
plus que le front national dans
certaines villes du département valeron
de saint-just arrive devant claude
bartolone
c'est le cas à rambouillet ou encore
amont que la ville une ville détenue par
le front national
sur l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines la liste du ps est en revanche
autour de 30% à la verrière guyancourt
ou encore trappe ville où siège dans la
majorité la responsable départementale
de la formation également candidates
on sait très bien que c'est pas un
département qui nous est favorable ça
les derniers résultats des élections me
montrer mais le la dans ce qu'il faut
c'est qu'on aille chercher tous les
électeurs de gauche
il existe dans ce département donc on a
une semaine pour convaincre maintenant
un fn à 18% c'est tout de même un score
important pour l'île de france valérie
pécresse aborde les 30%
c'est un score significatif mais qu'est
pas la percée attendue puisque a été
donnée à 32 33 % et le fn à 25% fait
mieux que les pronostics et on retrouve
le score de jean paul huchon en 2010
donc c'est plutôt une belle satisfaction
en 2010 selon paul huchon totalisé en
ile-de-france 25% il l'avait emporté au
second tour grâce au ralliement de la
gauche avec 56%
la coach qui espère une victoire
dimanche dans les yvelines elle a
enregistré ses meilleurs scores vous
l'avez vu que ce soit à trappes à la
verrière ou encore à guyancourt les
chiffres de trappes par exemple 33 75%
pour claude bartolone valérie pécresse
n'est que troisième la verrière claude
bartelone 29,76 % pour l'emporter et
néanmoins il faudra une alliance est ce
qu'elle est possible en tout cas nous
faisons le point avec olivier paréja
c'est le responsable europe écologie il
était candidat sur la liste europe
écologie on l'a dit tout à l'heure avec
vous stéphane minson europe écologie qui
voit son score fondre après 2010 / 2
voici ces réactions olivier parent et
jacquot secrétaire départemental
d'europe écologie hier
je pense qu'il ya une baisse qui est qui
et nationale qui est valable en ile de
france qui est la même dans les yvelines
donc après saint quentin en yvelines est
une ville parmi les autres je pense
qu'en 2010 on était dans une autre
dynamique c'était le rassemblement
d'europe écologie
il y avait toute la dynamique autour de
daniel cohn bendit chance qu'on est dans
la dynamique nationale n'y a pas d'échec
particulier ni sur saint-quentin ni sur
les yvelines on peut toujours rêver de
faire mieux de poursuivre les
les scores qu'on a fait jusqu'à présent
mais là on est un peu dans une amie qui
nationale c'est un petit peu difficile
localement d'arriver à ne pas s'inscrire
dans ce dans cet élan la cua la gauche
rassemblée qui l'emportent dimanche
prochain c'est un scénario qui en
général fonctionne ça marche bien ce
rassemblement de la gauche après une
division premier tour alors en tout cas
c'est mathématique
non ça n'est sûrement pas mathématique
et c'est beaucoup plus irrationnel que
déclarations qui ont été faites hier
soir ne le laissait supposer il ne faut
jamais au grand jamais additionner se
contenter d'additionner les voix du
parti socialiste le front de gauche et
puis les écologistes et puis ça fait
quarante noms et d'ailleurs ça m'a peut
être contre-productif wasyl attitude
peut-être de claude bartolone ses
premiers mots sa première déclaration
l'a entendue hier soir c'était la gauche
fait 40% nous sommes le premier parti en
ile de france vous allez tout le monde a
gagné hier soir enfin comme d'habitude
donc là aussi rien de rien de bien rien
de bien nouveau mais les électeurs ne
sont pas aussi aux tomates que cela ne
sont pas des moutons alors ils votent
peut-être plus par émotion que par
raison ça c'est un problème c'est une
question peut se poser savoir pourquoi
est-ce que l'affect l'emportent toujours
ou presque sur la raison
mais en tout état de cause les choses ne
sont pas aussi simples alors c'est
gagnable pour pour les listes bartolone
en ile de france
sûrement sauf que les réserves de voix
disponible
du côté des écologistes ont fondu de
moitié par rapport à ce qu'elle était en
2010 là il ne faut pas l'oublier
la troisième dans ce scrutin en tout cas
en ile-de-france est le front national
percée historique
néanmoins le résumé de la soirée depuis
le qg de valeron de saint-just avec les
équipes de radio sensations qui était
présente sur place aussi pour téléfilm
avec 18 points 41% des voix la liste
menée par va le rendre saint-just sera
au second tour le dimanche 13 décembre
en 2010 la liste front national avait
obtenu 8,83 % des suffrages
une progression soulevées par les
yvelinois présent sous les listes en ile
de france c'est toujours c'est plus
compliqué effectivement on est on est un
petit peu dans la bobosphère à paris
donc toute façon on sait que les
républicains font leurs meilleurs scores
ici ce qui est important c'est la
dynamique on progresse on progresse à
chaque élection on prend quelques points
on est toujours une marge de manoeuvre
une marge de progression sur l'île de
france
il faut regarder en arrêt quelques
années en arrière quand même les scores
qu'on faisait et les scores qu'on fait
maintenant il faut voir que la mener une
campagne très dynamique et qui sont je
pense à l'origine de ce score qui est
quand même une forte progression si sur
ce scrutin le front national obtient
près de dix points de plus qu'en 2010 la
liste menée par vallerand de saint-just
réalise un des moins bons scores sur
l'ensemble de la france
nous sommes
père de comparaître
la bretagne vous avez pas dire que la
bretagne est vrai gêné au gym
la france est diverse qu'on n'a pas
touché d'un résultat en pas grave au
nord pas de calais mais cela donne porte
à son résultat national
alwan orly
dans les yvelines le parti frontiste
obtient 19 05 % des suffrages se plaçant
là aussi en troisième position derrière
la candidate des républicains ou celui
du parti socialiste va la rendre
saint-just réalise son meilleur score
avec plus de 34% à l'autre la ville
commune dirigée par le maire frontiste
cyril notre troisième de la liste
yvelinoise sur 51 divine le parti se
classe 2e acrap devant valérie pécresse
sait très bien alors on fait 152 cela
dit au département à 11 1%
c'est bien mais peut servir fait pas
c'est pas non plus résultat exceptionnel
sur 30
non non il ya des scores plus
intéressant je vois plaisir par exemple
voient plaisir on est à 36 me soit 7 4
hier soir la grande saint-just faisait
un appel du pied aux électeurs de
nicolas dupont aignan le candidat de
debout la france a obtenu 6 57% des voix
la tête de liste francilienne n'a pas
donné de consigne de vote à ses
électeurs pour le second tour j'aurais
voulu vous faire réagir sur le front
national pas forcément uniquement sur
l'île de france mais pour savoir si la
aujourd'hui à l'issue du premier tour le
front national à travers l'hexagone
apparaît comme la première formation en
tout cas le grand vainqueur de ce
scrutin
à travers les chiffres mais est-ce que
c'est pas tout ça tout ça pour rien
parce que au second tour on l'a vu il ya
eu des désistements de certaines listes
et puis le front national n'a pas une
réserve non plus énorme de voir debout
la france éventuellement mais on ne sait
pas ce que font ses électeurs n'y a pas
eu de consigne de vote en tout cas est
ce que tout ça finalement va leur servir
à rien pour le front national
non nos noms en tout état de cause le
grand vainqueur une fois de plus de ce
scrutin c'est bien le front national qui
confirme là un ancrage un ancrage
territorial tel qu'on l'avait vu poindre
au municipal est tel qu'il avait été
consacrée aux départementales
même si il le nord pas de calais
picardie et provence alpes côte d'azur
sont assez probablement en voit tomber
dans l'escarcelle du front national mais
en tout état de cause ça ne ça ne
servira pas à rien parce que c'est très
très grande région dont certaines sont
la dimension et la population de
véritables états sont certes sur le plan
des compétences sur le plan financier
sur le plan budgétaire sont des nains ça
a pu être dit sont assez faibles
il reste que les présidents de ces
treize grandes régions métropolitaines
auront un poids politique bien
supérieurs à ceux des 22 anciens
présidents de région ça c'est
incontestable a ça va créer une
dynamique aussi avec notamment le
scrutin des présidentielles qui sera la
prochaine élection c'est une tribune
politique importante dont le front
national aurait bien tort de se priver
en vue de ce qui pourra se passer en
2010 est une dynamique pour le front
national on va s'arrêter justement avant
de conclure cette émission sur la 11e
circonscription des yvelines le
responsable front national nicolas beau
père était lui à elancourt le fn y
totalise 16 16% dans cette 11e
circonscription figurent aussi trois
pouces et 18% pour le score ce qui en
fait la deuxième formation dans cette
commune et lui il est assez satisfait
justement de la dynamique qui s'est
enclenchée les propos ont été recueillis
par camille lambert l'évolution ap
valence et qu'on va continuer à
travailler
c'est une belle avancée surtout se
regardent par rapport aux élections
européennes le front était arrivée en
tête mais avec moins de voix et
et un pourcentage un petit peu moins
élevée en été à 18,6 je crois là on a 18
8% elancourt j'ai comparé mois par
rapport aux départementales 2015
c'est-à-dire les dernières élections
pour lesquelles je me suis présentée en
mars 2015 afin de lui moi quoi
le front national a augmenté de 204 voix
et de près de plus de 2,3 points
moi je pense que les élans courtois
comment ça se rend compte de rendre
compte de l'enfumage permanent que l'ump
et du ps
cette édition spéciale du 7-8 politique
qui touche à sa fin aujourd'hui à lundi
on va jeter un dernier coup d'oeil aux
listes qui ont été qualifiés pour le
second tour vous voyez donc les trois
têtes de listes régionales qui
s'affrontent pour le second tour il
faudra donc aller voter une nouvelle
fois est dimanche à noter que tous les
résultats de toutes les communes sont à
retrouver sur notre site internet demain
mardi à 18h en direct le débat donc pour
le second tour avec david douillet
benoît hamon et philippe chevrier merci
stéphane minson professeur de droit
public à l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin d'être venu une
fois de plus comme à chaque élection
commenter ces différents résultats avec
nous je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée bien évidemment